what's up everybody welcome to stream
today we are playing telltale games new
game Batman
we are you've heard of Batman Beth I
have heard of Batman now what do you
know about Batman I know a troubled
childhood correct he's got issues one
escapes well played well played well
played
look at that bringing it back to Conan
it's awesome hello everyone hi hi brave
brave net cowboy Lenny Anderson Sergio
Garza I don't respond to those comments
Sergio Garza ooh hello
ring ring ring I just called Sergio's
bluff hello Esther just bluff there
click ah so let's play uh here's the
thing you can do is you can I think play
with us we're gonna try this new thing
that telltale games is doing called
crowd play I have no idea how it works
maybe you download an app probably and
you can help us decide what to do that's
right so hunter Fried Chicken Gurkha sh3
ah
Sergio Garza got him he goes Dan that's
right
nailed you sucker and lost in twitch
verse that's right and I can't see the
other comments cuz O'Malley put this
window over the other window but let's
play is all about making oh here we go
crowd play guys I think you can play
with us here we go everybody's vote
counts
thumbs-up down to show how you feel I
think you got to get a nap or something
telltale games app maybe pre-recorded
confirmed I love it I said listen to me
says Arriba okay here we go cool
yes tell tell tell tell guys good to see
you we're gonna do this crowd play thing
I'm very excited well played on this by
the way I think it's gonna be awesome
I crowd play mode allows a group of
people to make story choices together
participants get a game code they watch
your screen and vote with their own
devices playing via twitch or other
streaming services is not advised whoops
well too late we're gonna do it anyway
sorry we're gonna telltale games we're
gonna test your system to see what the
latency is we're used to the latency so
all right begin crowd play all right
guys this is the game code everybody
look at the screen and get the game code
yeah that's a good idea so far there's
only one person in the crowd and it's us
so PES will put up the game code I think
you could join as the game goes on so
you could join your foe so it's got a
telltale comm slash crowd play and put
in this game code that Beth is gonna
give you there we go hello from the UK
hello to you in gaming how do you play
elf manon here's how you play go to tell
Telecom slash crowd play MLG FBT if I
was smarter I would come up with an
acronym for that how about make lovely
games fun by trying yeah the game's fun
by trying there we go
start episode here we go oh I always do
I always do the thing as much as to the
right I always do the bright as possible
or very bright cuz I wants to look
around the dirt ooh what that tech color
should we do that
can we do rainbow this wouldn't be very
cool if you were Batman so this is like
rave back surface yeah I like this what
do you think I you know blue is good
purple seems a little I don't know if
you'd be into purple yellow feels like
evil yeah I say red or blue what do you
guys want to do Bruce Wayne is Batman
spoiler purple you say Tory I'm said
purple red King Irish says hey Team Coco
I do believe crap play is gonna work for
live-streaming we'll try red I'm seeing
a bunch of Reds red red red okay I'm
seeing red
red it is sorry we can't be tape we're
trying so forget it I'm seeing more Reds
than blues so I already did red sorry
sorry I lost in twitch worse it's the
back Guitar Hero drumset crazy bus go
man it did look like the bat Leah oh
yeah exactly
hey telltale games why not team up with
that's a good question rock band and
maybe somebody can play the drums you
decide which drum to hit no yes oh yeah
here we go
oh look and that thing is up in the
corner there that's kind of cool up in
the corner the the crowd play thing oh
cool that's great I'll see you can screw
up my choices oh no oh oh don't get
teenie without crowd play it's gonna
make me do it without crowd play Oh No
maybe we could try crowd play later I
was just gonna turn on the it's gonna
turn on subtitles subtitles are on I
guess no no someone joins can I
Oh weird oh we lost the connection I
think we lost it
I think it won't let us do it oh man we
tried guys but it did warn us by the way
it did warn us well it was but maybe
someday we can figure okay we're back
you guys will do crowd play you just
tell us in the comments what to do okay
sorry fam oh Jesus Christ
oh right off the bat the game starts
with a headshot
that's pretty city of Gotham here we go
someone said please explain the picture
on Instagram page I just put a picture
of me having the shirt I have issues so
it's Bruce Wayne by the way I appreciate
any gang that has like color-coordinated
stuff going that's what you think did
you do your did you do your look at that
did you do your research in terms of
timing the police they just let the dead
guy sit there in the chair
Jesus Gordon's got great hair that is
rough ten bucks says he feels most of
the time you know what we'll see about
that oh boy what the hell it's almost
like the elevators gonna come down I
feel like that wouldn't happen if an
elevator came down unless there was a
bomb in it
he's Batman dude Oh BAM ear doesn't kill
people idiot not unless you're talking
about as Azrael who is for a little
while I use Batman
Harvey Dent for mayor of Gotham so we
know it's before two-face
Arriva not fun watching this
pre-recorded stuff see ya by Arriva it's
not pre-recorded but thanks oh here we
go boom you guys gonna do both episode 1
& 2 or just 1 if we can we have we have
to if there's time ah love he's like
who's this guy getting for the face get
him in the face
you're a terrible gang member
[Music]
guy just like wets himself it was pretty
cool seeing how Conan what this is how I
hang out at home - just like shirtless
by my fire they need something to fear
Oh God he's just leaving blood trail
Emma oh here we go
Oh we're kind of cutting between the two
look how it dives right into combat yeah
this is great a big like story everybody
knows about it is yeah exactly man I
can't wait for a movie that just like
you don't need the backstory to fifty
like Suicide Squad I heard that's why
it's sucked there was like it was all
backstory like 50 people and that who
cares doesn't matter you know I'm saying
just tell us the story dude oh the
picture when I went to Germany Tory says
what picture whoa look at this
which picture when I went to Germany the
one where Conan had a crazy face on cuz
that was dope I can't spoil stuff from
the episode man oh man first rule a
Batman don't go for the guy that's bait
bro oh yeah
oh yeah get him
right in the leg whoo yeah here we go oh
I love it
pulling me to the darkest best part of
the job man striking fear who know we oh
we've got a formation whoo I'm so scared
cut - not scared
Batman [ __ ] what if it was an 8-ball oh
yeah
stay tuned well if you looked at Conan's
thing what did Kony's things say I think
he said what he did right or no there
may or may not be the date if you were
to visit such a web address oh let's get
him I don't understand what I'm doing
here press X and mu Oh
oh dude this is dope looks like your
friends are just hanging around thank
you up top he didn't have to come at me
bro
oh dude I'm into this action situation
it does it's great I love this cell
shading - looks don't just run away on
Batman run away what are you doing oh
dude come on man
oh whoops this is much quicker I'll say
than other telltale games it feels like
I mean as well it should be oops I won
this says Britney [ __ ] on it yeah there
we go yup there we go hey you little
minx
damn
dude do you think Batman would be good
at dancing or bad at dancing Blake I'm
not talking about that time I in the
club dude into club into club oh my god
I'm Batman [ __ ] latest suckas
if you guys are into comic book Paul
Pope who's a great indie comic book
maker did a great Batman series called
Batman year one hundred in the future
and it's really cool because Batman eats
it's drawn it's such a way that the guy
isn't a billionaire and so he wears like
a gym suit and like the way he goes up
it's like he has all these carabiners
and stuff and he like pulls him and he
goes up and he wears fake fangs and it's
kind of like a retelling of the Batman
is in the future where like people can
like read people's thoughts and stuff
and it's very like ultra paranoid but
it's really cool because it's very like
I don't know you he doesn't have all the
gadgets it's kind of like it's awesome
it's called fat man year 100 by Paul
Pope it's like it's for quick issues
that's awesome Sydney needs protecting
anti-hero girl you never seen my God
we're so pretentious don't you know not
to call I bet she lives in West
Hollywood it's dangerous
she like lives in West Gotham like Susan
Cage I do hot yoga bring that okay I'll
never hit a woman but I'll definitely
I'm gonna kiss you so hard Catwoman I'm
gonna punch my face your face with my
face am I seriously fighting kattleman
what's up Batman would never let this go
down yep
that's actually not a bad idea
a couple years ago I wanted fiance and
just had a wig and a white shirt just
hit Beyonce Herman oh man
not the moneymaker girl they scratching
up my bruce wayne efface geez I won't
say the one thing that I bet I mean I
know this guy dresses up like a bat now
this stuff well the one thing that kinda
has never rung true oh my god I just
punched a girl in the stomach
what
wait what is this a bomb wait what is
that this you just did Connor it's a fun
little fight that's gonna be on the news
everybody
is that a pager it's just not she's got
a pager
hey big boy page me can't they put it in
the in the training manual not just
shoot that man how many people does he
have to save before people like that go
dear
but I was gonna see the one thing they
never is wrong true to me about Batman
is he he's a millionaire playboy he
would never be able to get away from the
paparazzi you know like it would just be
like well yeah I mean like people
immediately would know look at me just
stealing that hard drive oh who shot
Batman dude no wait that's the bad news
wait Harbor to you by the way
oh great question here's why I think
Batman is great because bat hey I missed
her Oh an elder oh no I got to go save
her
ah because Batman is a master strategist
that's what people don't normally that's
his biggest edge is he never gets into
he always has a way out
you know it's like he never walks into a
room he doesn't know how to walk on
that's one thing that the movies never
really get right like one of my favorite
Batman stories is the law of Halloween
because it's really mostly about and the
long Halloween is a story it's kind of
like a retelling of Harvey Dent how he
became two-face it's fantastic Jeff love
and who's the other guy who did it and
it's like twelve issues and takes place
like over a year and it has like all of
fans villains in it but it's also about
it's also about that maybe detective and
like trying to figure out it's somebody
is killing all these other all the
villains there's just going around like
killing it's like a serial killer who's
killing all the Batman's enemies and so
Batman is like a detective it's very
like spooky and all that stuff but
that's one thing the movies that kind of
never get right which is interesting
like you know like the first one I think
Batman Begins kind of comes the closest
because you see him training it needs to
cut trying to figure it out but the last
one is just like him just fighting Bane
it's like what them so I think it would
be Batman that's what what's Iron Man
without the suit yeah he hits it with an
EMP screw yeah you know like two stones
be your family like yeah Tony Stark is
just a drunk who has you know Tony Stark
is kind of it's interesting because I
think Tony Stark is what Batman would be
without done without the like [ __ ]
yeah you know without like all that
stuff cuz he said he's a millionaire
playboy and he's super smart obviously
but he doesn't have like the detective
skills yeah that Batman has and that's
what sets them apart that's why I think
thank you Tim sail
thank you rebuilding aru's jeff lobik
himself is not used to such a ringing
endorsement then they did another one
that was not as good before you got
about Robin for too long Batman could
take out Superman Iron Man 2 yes he can
Batman vs Superman the problem it wasn't
terrible Harvey just fine is a lot of
punching we put your foot down
uh I like Ben Affleck's there's a great
photo by the way on my Instagram of
Ben Affleck bumping into me which is
hilarious mr. Wayne I can pay ya he's I
like him a lot he would oh I do play
nothing I love video games do real
Eminem what's up say hi Bruce gotta say
I do like video games I like the
storytelling Oh mr. Webb that's what I
love about video games now is they tell
such a great that's a telltale telltale
games does really well if they tell
great stories they tell Batman verse to
read sucks it's fine I mean who cares
mr. Wayne
thank you for opening you it's a big
action movie so and the action is fun
this is the biggest mansion in Gotham
but I don't think you got lost on your
way here where were you Tom O'Neill is
there a limit for ten minutes of one for
you to answer and then guys in the chat
no there's just a delay oh [ __ ] I messed
up yes came here tonight to see me rump
and I can see him just fine from here
shouldn't be painful it's not a kidney
stone it's only a little face time with
potential donors your face
specifically with it my plate right now
with the grease Aaron Decker did play a
great Harvey done and they're rolling in
enough cash and boats to help make
Gotham a place for families again aaron
eckart has a great kind of like
pretentious pretty boy or home where did
you feel like Harvey Dent is once he
wasn't he was ah sound as mayor Cohn
apparently hate the spin doctors all
right oh oh really I don't remember that
is in Harvey
together you and me oh right right right
oh yeah I forgot that city free from a
lot of great games coming out later this
here push north yes we're planning a
bunch of close gamers very excited
we have to shake things up to make that
happen well that was yeah oh yeah you're
right yeah I won sorry Tom I the chat
goes by real fast I can only see a
couple questions
please ask Conant Windwalker and hog for
him he's asked under different Christmas
decorations please no goofy hamburger
sup as bona fide decorations please and
thank you
one of the reasons that we don't
actually do Christmas decorations or
decorations on the satellite it's
because I mean what's all the tape
what's called a copy if we're traveling
or doing something let's take a couple
pieces of shows while we're doing other
shows so let's say after all I got a
Monday we might tape like one extra yes
someone like you too and so we'll
assemble that into a show so we'll do
that very far ahead which would mean
that we couldn't take all the
decorations off the set but just for one
segment or put them on the set for a
second right if we're doing a cobbler
let's say somebody really famous showbiz
secret I kinda you kind of know what
this party is all this champion what is
the ETA on the walking at season 3
telltale forgive me whoever's in the
chatlin telltale that's a good question
for ya can't the Walking Dead was Doctor
Who telltale now you're talking best
language witch doctor depends on the man
script such as dressing up in a bat
costume and taking out the criminals who
ruin our city King Irish
yes conan beats me up all the time he
actually beats me up and do anymore
[Music]
his thing now is because now I've lost a
bunch of weight so when he hits me he
says it's like punching a bag just like
oh you're a bag of bones so now he'll
grab me and you'll throw me in his stuff
the wall threw me into a metal cabinet
there oh I haven't played wolf among us
yet Michel Gerard Gerald Michael Joan I
have it down low anyway it was doing
yay tent for 10th doctor tragedy my god
this guy's tie I want to punch this dude
in the face there this time Oh deranged
man had gotten the right treatment maybe
yeah thanks for sympathy always take the
high road guys and Telltale Games being
a soccer man it'd be a good place to see
there's no killing mr. Saul he's like
head and legs just like the city's just
punch him in the knees
mr. Dennis I'm saying we're on our way
or say a couple unkind words and then
let his mind tear itself apart from the
inside with rage I like FIFA yeah we
might play fifa next week yeah we final
three fun times I hear it's great oh I'm
terrible at it
I have played Game of Thrones we play
Game of Thrones Elena Anderson right
here on stream Coco
Harvey Dent Gotham's next I should fight
back he gets Conan one day souls on 11
says I don't know I do like having a job
at a paycheck let's be fight dumb shirts
like this orders aloud
well you don't mind if I say Vicki Vale
you put up ruies Nazis bad dance by the
way actually I'm here to keep it off the
refugees it's Prince didn't do that song
yeah you're gonna want to link to that
guys everyone in the chat are gonna want
to check out this link she's putting on
Mickey
Vicky Vale Vale they do Dan bungle I
would love to see a telltale Star Wars
game that's like for rogue one would be
joke that would be fun
well I can't wait for ro go on I'm very
excited I started watching the trailers
for road one
because I've seen enough you have my
money Bruce Wayne has a Ewing year round
yeah well I'm sure it's is the way of
life blubber some dogs sure life dumb
shirt life it's blood of course it is
first real Fight Club don't talk about
Fight Club Vicky Vale cut myself shaving
this no that's nothing it's just
I saw myself shaving if I shaving I mean
with beating the crap out of bad guys
kidding
excuse me dude how ripped is hardly dick
Jesus guest has arrived the digit joker
Falcone who is that carmine Falcone knew
it is the dent campaign soliciting votes
from God who tells how stranger things
would be good convicted of anything
except being a businessman who loves
this city
excuse us I'm sorry brother Todd I
didn't see I your comment earlier but
props to you Count Dooku rules its his
arms cut off by the one car garage this
do you think easy Dan is Jack one that
controls enough votes to get me into
City Hall this is the necessary evil
politics Bruce he kind of looks a little
bit josh brolin ESCO it's all of us at
least hear him out before you so quote
the marshal only requested to speak with
you there we go
thank you Bruce seriously you know what
I have to poop ha ha low lows ooh pod
says there's Star Wars character who's
your favorite Beth favorite Star Wars
character is tough O'Malley you got a
favorite Star Wars character
goofy Yoda ig-88 he likes you but that's
the robot bounty on her nice pull wait
who do you look like when wind Yoda is
like like being like a go by yes
siliceous barosky there's a weird thing
where somebody put I think I put my
extreme a long time ago there are Star
Wars Episode somebody made a fan art of
Conan is Jabba and me is salacious beat
no ref you screw you Falcone Beth looks
more like a Jar Jar Binks man how dare
you how come remember that good I'll
beat the crap out of Falcone see Vicki
Vale was gonna see us shaking hands me
don't ya more comfortable Darth Maul is
dope you're right drunken rampage
Chewbacca is great low bond you guys
haven't seen by the way Bethel put a
link to it Star Wars called up and we're
Conan's really he's a [ __ ] Lobot
it's awesome on guys Bruce I saw plenty
of skirts to keep you busy for a few
minutes how he comes to me dude hope he
stays with us a man's home is his castle
I respect that see also Hardy's Jack's
uh Tory well you have Ellen DeGeneres on
the livestream of course who well if she
wants to come over here oh yeah what
spooky game should we play we should
play the wolf alone yes telltale right I
see I'll let me see Ellen riding her
bike understand and I'd rather see how
we actually help this city instead it is
and Sweden Batman actually has I believe
in Harvey Dent
wait who's my favorite Star Wars
character we didn't answer I like it
obi-wan I think Obi Wan's cool he's
chill you know what I'm saying he's
chill man I uh favorite DC character
great question so I mean what's that
man's awesome the Hulk's my favorite
Marvel character drama loose fall me
yeah I can get Harvey the Miko it was a
mistake to kill Darth Maul so soon
however we choose I will see that's
probably why Boba Fett are you such a
big cuz you know you leave one more no
what am i cool no to see Darth Maul like
in another movie or like to come back
like if he gets injured negan
Tina get her Rick me it's an a-hole
negan he's the worst
I'm a come on move five nights at
Freddy's to be great brutal damn track
hoe Pass vs. Evil Dead love ash vs. Evil
Dead one who can help mister dead see
the lines
between your businesses and mine I bet
we employ half the city now we got a
good thing going so I don't see why we
shouldn't team up
oh I'm everyone's friend which means you
really know what's wrong with the
Patronus they find out what your
Patronus is Harry Potter no my Patronus
is a penguin everybody knows that big
flightless bird that's me that is me
awkward flightless ladies left out in
the cold like waddle when I walk also
people don't say no to me not for long
it's got a real lumpy face get old Bobo
face yes
alien isolation would be great I played
a lot alien isolation on my personal
stream was very scary for a long time
heed your Butler's advice kid oh he'll
beat this level for the stream ends I'll
play Joe so the owners of freak and he's
gonna get what's coming Jill Oh bring it
sell code
but I didn't get fennel gone anarchy ooh
anarchy is great and Ricky's a great
Batman villain Tanner York I mean wow
that's just the pretty cool ahh that's
Batman villain I mean Harvey Dent's good
two-face is great because him and bat
him and Bruce used to be friends
the Joker is you know I hate to say it
classic cuz he's opposite Batman's
controlled I thought you know that's why
I think Heath Ledger did such a great
job because he really truly is like the
opposite it's kind of like when you'll
indulge me for a second the 80s rock
music everyone was like hair glam all
this stuff and then grunge came into the
90s and just highlighted how dumb all
that was it's moving like Kurt Cobain
these guys are just wearing like normal
t-shirts playing it was just like look
at all these idiots like you know you
know and Dokken and poison at least oh
yeah and so that's kind of I feel like
how it is with the Joker he kind of is
like hey look out what an idiot Batman
you know
oh he's so you know whatever so I like
the Joker a lot that was just the it's
all pretty cool man
you know I tell us sir the Riddler is
great Mark Hamill is the best Joker
agree has to be Joker has to be Joker -
Poland hello [ __ ] neck
yeah they complete each other exactly
the chair plays I agree Silent Hill
would be fun me like pearl why would I
keep those tickets that's so depressing
Dakin you remember Dakin mr. Frese
captain quasar I like mr. Frese de
Batman villain because he's not truly
it's interesting because he's a guy who
people don't know Mr Freeze he's doing
that to save his wife he's trying to
save his wife so like he and it kind of
makes you think like what would you do
if you were you know if you need it if
you were driven to desperation by
somebody love like you want to save this
person you love you know what I'm saying
and it's not too different from Batman
Batman Bruce Wayne he's avenging his
parents you know what I'm saying but
what if his parents were all alive one
of his he could save his parents he
might not be that different from mr.
freeze you know what I'm saying like a
smart guy like who's ready to yeah
whatever
should we go for this i do love when i
play games myself i'll go through with
all this stuff when I complete moves on
a stream I kind of like to just keep
keep it moving
it was data drives whoo we gotta build
mr. Freeze's character was butcher in
the new 52 I don't know what that means
I didn't look at the new 52 what's up
Sam Enzo I love dr. doom really think
he's doing it that's for the world yes
crime job Chris I feel like dr. doom
might be the best villain around he's
certainly like the most powerful he's
insane he's told Galactus his power at
one point no one knows what that means
except for me but in the beat and he
beat the Beyonder which was incredible
and secret worse I'm getting my
virginity back as I'm talking more about
this stuff he knows a bunch of magic
he fought Doctor Strange once said that
he connect he was so good at magic he
might be the he could maybe take over a
sorcerer supreme it was kind of crazy
he's uh got great political power as the
ruler of Latveria he's as smart as Reed
Richards it's smarter some would say
Richards and by the way if you've all
Brecon my Michael Bendis I'm going hard
nerd stuff today you follow Brian
Michael Bendis who's a great a great
comic book writer he's just started
writing the new in the new Iron Man
Doctor Doom becomes Iron Man he takes
over very interesting Ben Affleck's
decision to bring Deathstroke on the
screen is great oh my god is Deathstroke
gonna be on the screen cuz Deathstroke
is amazing it does stroke a lot in a lot
of ways is like Batman's equal in terms
of being a strategist only he's only got
one eye but I can't wait to see
Deathstroke voice modulation Wayne
Enterprises really outdid themselves
with this version favorite Doctor Who
episode Oh mine's the one with the
Pandorica Pandorica opens I think ah
because they twist is so great I also
really liked what was another really
good man goes to war
what's the good man goes to war that's
Arthur is like in them it's like baby oh
yes yes yeah what is that the one where
Amy's that is future Amy it's like the
end of the thing with oh wait where
she's in like a white room yeah no idea
but there's like all the tenant whenever
I watched any I can watch there's not
that many I like the one there was a
good one where someone were you ever
they go into the future Amy they leave
her in this music heartbreaker oh I love
being deke in the speak world geeking
geek world Doctor Who's great
a blank every says blank but I think I
want the doctor's damn bangle yes I've
played all the Arkham's except for
Arkham origins I'll take a beat all
actually
where am I going here how do I get out
of here anyone Oh blink is great yeah
what are we talking about
blink is horrifying joins us the movie
with three doctors is not wait why am I
here stack up member do you mean on this
earth or what my favorite Marvel villain
well we did talk about doctor do purple
man's great I mean any villain who
thinks that they're doing dog I've got a
fever leave yeah in front of a computer
I'll leave as soon as I finish people
with regular jobs can do their work
anywhere but for me it's worth playing
justify death track fair I agree it
isn't normal work which came to come to
pick up the quickest none of them finds
out I'm sorry yeah well good deeds
usually going up just purple man it's
great
no not unappreciated Oh Magneto's great
yeah Magneto's great because yeah uh-oh
man Brainiac versus Ultron Brainiac of
course
and that Brainiac might be the greatest
villain he's super smart there's a great
also if you got again if you like comic
books there's a great story told by
Grant Morrison who's one of my favorite
authors where Lex Luthor from a
different dimension comes to our
dimension a harder dimension the good
dimension he comes from a dimension
where he's the only good guy fighting an
evil justice Lee and so he's good Lex
Luthor coming to our thing and he's legs
drugs and he asked the heroes to come to
fight the bad Justice League and like
Superman is like a dig in like Oh
impotent and is always hitting on Wonder
Woman and she sucks and like they're
like they're like enslaved humanity and
it's really great and it turns out while
you should watch it but it's great
Brainiac is in there too it's really fun
but that was a great and it made me like
appreciate Brainiac is like a pretty
good guy also Dark Knight Returns Frank
Miller who did a sequel which is
absolutely insane the dark era turns
darker it's amazing and a lot of stuff
including super the Superman Batman
fighting but he did a great thing where
blood stains are much harder to remove
from a tuxedo we're bringing nothing
yeah Brainiac is like the heat easily to
take over the world I'd already seen you
up once tonight I know if you can tell
for minor talk I'm not married
there you go for the record your father
distraught they ruined Gotham Stella
reputa my spectacle might be welcoming
back some people though people like this
Catwoman aren't helping if she new to
town never seen her before
Lex I just wanted to save you the world
that's why you hate Superman as he has
to take that right Joseph there's also a
great Superman red Sun oh man we're
getting into the comic books today
Superman red Sun is an Elseworlds idea
written by somebody great I can't think
of right now where Superman lands in
Russia so he becomes over a thing and so
it's like Lex
there who's like America's greatest hope
versus Superman whose Russia's greatest
hope and that's the thing is like Lex
he's like fighting against an alien and
it's interesting the interesting take
because you kind of realize like yeah
like if it was another country like Lex
would be seen as a good guy fighting an
evil menace so that's kind of cool and
the end of Superman red Sun is fantastic
and I'd it'll blow your mind it's great
look we're just reading the blogs
reading the blogs
we've accessed the Codex what am I
supposed to be doing yet this is the
problem when I don't pay attention haha
you're welcome to let me like pearl fing
fan Fin Fang Foom is great but it's Fin
Fang Foom who's by the way a giant
dragon and the Iron Man comics he's like
a friend of the Mandarin right
but his Fin Fang Foom a bad guy or a
good guy the thing is we I know a lot of
the stuff about Batman so I'm just gonna
fly through this veil Vicki Vale Vicki
Vale and who's Hamilton he'll never seen
this oh he's the mayor of Gotham City
not for long alright much to find
apparently few burglaries break-ins
that's why 2020 Gore out pretty low
James Winona talking to from her new
come step out shooting 911 my first
video game Oh might have been Robin Hood
on the commodore 64 or maybe something
with the Odyssey I'm super old so honest
he was part re mas namaste namaste
I read stuff from Mark Miller there you
go mark millar also mark Miller did a
great comic book if you guys like Batman
no one that stuff called nemesis and the
idea of nemesis is what if Batman was
the Joker this guy is like a super rich
it's like Batman being a man a dick but
it's really great it would end it was it
was cool I'm sure they're gonna make
nemesis into a movie oh my god you see
this look at this I know I said that I
was like oh that's true she is a twin
Beth is a twin Norma Colonel's coming
next week every times great Tony Succar
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne he's got the
darkness soul it's all gift and dark
curse taskmasters okay
but connie isn't taskmaster just a
low-rent Deathstroke ended up saying
even though he trains other guys he's
like Deathstroke of Deathstroke as a
teacher
I thought I saw eyes and what 20 years I
think fires to syllabub czar one I don't
know what that means in grade school
indeed
you two were thick as thieves sorry
Adina's there's your welcome it's
relieving you I would love to go to
sweet Pleasant his arms dealing prison
stints
bye cutie 911 if I'm using hit kick off
an Amiga 500 I remember fortunately you
are Boswell claimed he wanted to catch
us eh-eh-eh yes
troubling why he's returning home I
haven't the faintest idea
do you think he might know something
about the braking Marvel's ripped off
listen T C's characters what are you
talking about captain quasar might not
be a coincidence
let's hear it well let's hear your
reasoning ruse they may be Deathstroke
adepts Balaam's the same you're insane
Connie is the fun kind of trouble that's
wrong Deadpool are not even close to
this I even though you and young mom
first of all Deadpool is regenerated are
generating fool super funny destro I'm
Glenn Felice lead Wilson a little more
serious it's got one eye so we can't
regenerate he's just super smart
Deadpool just runs into things
Deathstroke is like a like I said master
strategist I said corner doesn't here an
idiot we have a lot of fans out there
Foot Clan versus putty patrol I don't
know putty Patrol Robert life field
ripped off Deathstroke yes he did it's
the truth too much to list you're insane
Wade Wilson Slade Wilson whatever where
are you hey bees music what's up wait
Slade I'm in denial you just haven't
made a good case friend Miko Oh JA
taskmasters probably wanna let's kill
form our shelters to Marvel that's true
I agree with that also he can his whole
thing is he can just by looking at
someone he can imitate them right why do
i this is a bad idea
see this is what I'm talking about if
Bruce Wayne just went outside and walked
around you there be paparazzi everywhere
it's like Brad Pitt walking around Thank
You Ravi Rajesh Kate thank you for
coming
let's examine them this is a pretty game
yeah you're right
Bohdan live we are coming in and why see
I don't know if tickets are available my
tumblr page is hilarious thank you me
like bro
too soon Marvel can it but put it but
pudding I will say Marvel has figured
out a way to make those movies very fun
which is good so I think it's easier to
like them
right DC trying to take a statue but
I would love to kept this on what's the
last time I squatted on the beach I
don't do squats on the beach I squat in
the gym the beach I like to workout when
I'm at the beach I like to just hang out
yeah so cheese phenomenal can't wait I'm
in math waiting for this the worst comic
book characters slayed add one one
character that I will say he's known as
the worst but actually Frank Miller
makes a good point his Plastic Man is
one of the most dangerous characters
Plastic Man could basically turn into
anything and he's crazy and so he could
he's unkillable which is great so
Plastic Man
scene is a dumb character but I love
when they like reboot characters and
make them cool like I'm totally into
that like they kind of took elongated
man Ralph's dibs or Ralph's nibs or
Ralph's something and made him like a
cool detective like I like when they do
that when they take lame characters and
really launched them it's fun my friend
Sam Humphries who writes a bunch of
x-men books and that stuff check him out
he wrote the whole series called the
black vortex has done that I have played
The Walking Dead telltale Laura Jackson
it's great used Irish spuds yes Plastic
Man is completely insane
but he's great he's totally crazy and
unkillable Frank Miller doesn't make no
sense but he's fun
I love dark Boise oh look a shopping
cart I'm out up here we go watch wallet
cash go through you
dude that's that's way too short to go
through me you heard it man I've got
nothing hell are you waiting for
nothing except old owner enlightening
I've got nothing and him hahahaha how
dramatic keep walking all right don't
concern you awesome Arkadiy as he Jesus
Oh Gunter
seems to be a noise I do like that one
moment in the dark night where when the
Joker comes to Bruce Wayne's party Bruce
Wayne's walking and he he just grabs the
guy with the shocking like disassembles
it and just drops it you know lay in
pieces without flinching it's good by
the way let's talk about action movies
for a second Batman John wick great
movie super fun it's really fun it's
just a great like it's unapologetically
an awesome action I mean it's not as
good as the rain which isn't the same
but they just released so John wick too
is coming out and they're released a
behind the scenes video of Keifer
Sutherlands just talk you through
Sutherland Keanu Reeves doing live ammo
training yeah I keep but um with Keanu
Reeves doing live ammo training just a
couple and it's like better than any
it's better than any trailer they could
release for John wick - it's so cool
it's amazing
yeah Keira Amber's John wick was great
because he went on a rampage over a
puppy okay I know that's why it's great
it didn't take itself too seriously
Candice Sutherland exactly they never
saw John wick is great certainly duck
it's a shame what happened it was
beautiful once oh I haven't seen the
Magnificent 7 yet I've seen the original
Batman 92 but inside favorite game the
last five years dude wipe the blood off
your face it's driving me crazy I know
you know like Beth and I have a booger
packed you know like if I have a booger
photo tell me if you booger out so you
we also need to have a blood back if I
my face is covered in bloody Anne tell
me
maybe doesn't know maybe doesn't know
this face what you know what though if
you want to make your eyes bleed don't
do this but nobody knows you could do
this and you'll make your eyes go
terrible I'm sure don't mess you up ah
relic I have read a bunch of them
Ultimate Marvel Comics I like him a lot
the blood makes you cool oh West world
looks awesome
I agree captain quasar just finished
watching mr. robot last week which is
almost 90 days that's your fleabag is
bringing Amazon we back supposed to be
phenomenal my friend ven Berman told me
bought it what if there was a baby who
could no longer age that would suck
because they'd be stuck as a baby bunch
second green in the back of his throat
or maybe but that'd be terrible I like
the self awareness of being an adult I
would you know like it's like they made
him contemporary favorites carried a
game demon tous asks I like the alien
isolation a heck of a lot if you need
pain inside is kind of a creepy ass game
yeah and maybe go like sorry Mike
bothers is a good show Steve 994 I love
the rock I haven't seen any ballers but
I love rob corddry also do I have a dog
no mr. robot was awesome mr. robot
shadow the light is a great USA series
about a hacker it's fantastic you can't
wait for Lou my god it's Atrix what I
think you still got some are as I got
older but you'd be small you couldn't
reach the pedals of a car and drive
around like that would be terrible you
couldn't you couldn't find any roller
coasters as a baby oh I've got great
affection for you Bruce oh really
oh my god are they regen yes we are of
course
which way to buy lost JJ ninety pounds
but I'm gaining some of it back putting
muscle you know trying to trying to get
those muscles good gut show we're
watching I know you're talking about
Jay's house the other half of
Mythbusters do what do you mean
cuz I look like Jamie or Adam thank you
publicly Jamie I need a braise that
you're saying yeah I would love to be
part of Mythbusters Mythbusters is
fantastic actually somebody from Nerdist
Kyle Hill just got named as they're
making a Mythbusters spin-off show he
got named as the host congratulations to
Kyle and to our friends at Nerdist
thanks Kira Adam Savage fair enough
those Mythbusters guys are great I'd be
happy to be associated with them in any
way later TV divine good luck in your
calc class I failed calc so pay
attention
yoicks faded stoner thanks for joining
us ignore a man
you've reported for 2018 a scores I mean
mine is as fast as the paint's rustle we
didn't go to comic-con Dima Santos shows
there for last year's Terrell ants
report of your triggering I don't know
what you mean by trigger silent but ever
since it thank you or I'm sorry welcome
depending on a particular background for
the criminally insane Chris Scott this
is great we're playing you guys who's
joining us crew ah its security Luckey
play telltale games new Batman series so
far it's really fun get you right into
the action even more dangerous than
before they what's up at a press
conference I love Bruce is flirting with
Alfred like I'm text that's great what
are you wearing what you what you are
usable contribution from this man beard
we break ground this is our
state-of-the-art mental health do you
bleed Michael Jeff one that will improve
the well-being of Gotham and its sister
Alex J for years that's cheap car and
mr. Wayne has a few words we'd like to
say Bruce
Oh Catholic boys are triggering be
offended by something online oh no
Darrell amps well thank you for joining
us sorry we're offending you fantastic
elements are often in I guess you hate
crime fighting but inside they're so
lined up on the Iron Throne says King
max I think it's gonna be Jon Snow I
think Daenerys is going to be his wife
because they you know they have a
history of incestuous relationships and
they're gonna combine that fight the
White Walkers and
here oh you're gonna get to hard stood
up to approach ya to our throats or
maybe should be Daenerys man
no matter the cost you know she is like
the Targaryen she's be a descent of the
Targaryen exhaust
you know after Robert's rebellion guys
let's get into it after Robert's
rebellion that was a rebellion really so
the car I don't think whatever the
Lannisters have a right to the throne
sure you know they just manipulate other
way up there the Targaryen czar the true
or maybe she'll be at our Garret the
Targaryen will be my hopes and heart I
think maybe Daenerys 20 leagues between
and they meet John will be like her hand
to be pretty no like that I'd like to
see that that would be great again
you're do deep Riggs is too obvious dude
what do you think Shashank what do you
guys stand faithful Knight we dedicate
this facility to Thomas and Martha Wayne
sure Dominic if we have time we played
up said to you first
Gendry what happens I don't know a lot
of the names there's like fifty thousand
ooh it's days past Arkham is only done
harm to God that's right never word
escapes from Arkham any waiting so why
I'm still good thing they jumpin you
don't know say we can do better
there we go all right who's up next
Tyrion is also Targaryen I don't know JJ
my sources say you welcome to legend mob
boss carmine Falcone who's my favorite
youtuber who it's a good question and
mr. denty great YouTube yourself behind
closed doors I love my girls I'm a
unicorn she's great I love
gosh folks are awesome cable erta but I
love I love how to be / is fantastic
please keep your questions on top of
people no classroom team kokis is 2020
garage but mr. Wayne this morning the
glow proceeded evidence of an offshore
bank account managed by Carmine's yeah
now it's like the the books of this show
are kind of two different things
transaction is connected to organized
crime going back years and continuing to
visit youtubers why captain quasar they
don't watch YouTube there's a lot of how
to give youtubers no comment I don't
comment on rumors why don't we just
stick to real journalism could the
allegations be true what are you telling
us because the mob
my notion Sanders sounds to me like an
intern is finally putting their creative
writing minor to good use
yeah it's guys just videotaping the
backs of people's head it's coming from
Falcone I've been fielding your
questions from here on out
do I read much all the time right now
I'm reading feet superiors by Lauren
Groff it's fantastic my favorite books
on time please are inside the manor
doing what what go p-- love dr. strange
is a character don't know about the
movie we'll see I like to see more
diversity in movies guys I don't know
about till the switch very cool look
tell us what not sure that's a great
this Warren J jonah Jameson own personal
I had the boys turn the lights off
people no problem your job well I got
nothing to hide except a giant bat cave
all my vigilante toys purple man Len H
purple man is Jessica John the teachers
Jessica Jones he pebble man is
traditionally a daredevil villain in
that world Luke Cage all those people
Hell's Kitchen crew and he can make
people do whatever kind of like Jesse
Custer and preacher and any companies
you own your holdings are ready clear
one movie connie stream I love the love
the book that actually thought it should
have been three boroughs interesting Lee
enough when I had yes and Spielberg is
amazing I love the fact he's doing that
movie because he's mentioned a lot in
blow and so I think they a big enough
movie like Spielberg is doing well I
think they might be able to get the
licensing for a lot of those characters
it's a lot about the eighties and stuff
and I think they did you tab jaws
actually in it would be fantastic I
think wouldn't have a lot we spilled
we're buying the helm that can actually
get the budget and the licenses people
would trust him so I'm really excited
he'll knows if I go deeper my man nearly
destroyed the adventures I believe
that'd be a real shame I haven't seen
Jessica Jones but I did see Christian
Ritter and the car next to me last week
right outside that studio that's good
she seems awesome she got I looked I was
like rocking out a reason why is I was
rocking out really hard to some jams and
I look over and she was looking at me
like laughing I was like cool Krysten
Ritter I love you
kilgrave yeah that's his real name
yes 30s star interesting his game my
shirt says I have issues but it could
say I have tissues but I don't have
tissue so to be alive mr. M from Herman
Koch okay I will thank you to do this
boat in live you should watch you should
read ready parent player one persevere
it's really good
you know what as Bruce Wayne ever
thought about maybe a little therapy for
saying you know like if you're dressed
up like interrupt bat and beating people
up that's fine I'm not gonna judge but
on the other hand you kind of feel like
really also if you lose wandering into
my house we're not just allowed to come
into my house dude autumn continues its
streak of break-ins I'm ready for loot
change can't wait life is great shade
next how's your life I mean like bro I
like no man's sky a lot of media
meatheads is their business person 18
what's your what's your regular service
you can just buy old-fashioned you know
I've never played dishonored one we're
filming in the ruins dishonor to looks
dope and it's all hearsay flimsy sources
there isn't a shred of hard proof still
allegations like this it'll magically
appear someone is doing no man sky was
overhyped it doesn't mean it's not a fun
game obviously the sender didn't
identify themselves we have no idea who
it could be
I mean no one's even done I don't feel
one looks great also very excited for
the fumble they grab the ball and ring
this politically motivated I think we
all know that he wins in a landslide
Danny would go mad like her father Joey
you at the White Walkers the humans
here's one thing though that some people
sometimes are saying I know we're gonna
get into some deep we were saying that
the Mad King went crazy because of Brent
what bran is doing he went back in time
and made the magnet going back because
not all the Targaryen czar crazy by the
way talking about this is in life first
there's only hips that's interesting I'm
doing great I sweat a swath right now as
far as the movies go which is my
favorite spider-man I've only seen on
the record then well on the records go
quote whenever you're ready
my family's innocent the winged family
has always been a cornerstone of Gotham
we have never had and never will have
connections to organized crime that is
Joker really the Batman from the future
no Joker is just a guy who's crazy yeah
you're gonna B's not everything doesn't
need to be kidnappings always come out
on top
goodbye miss Whelan I don't watch Gotham
I only watch two shows I only watch like
one or two shows in time my watchman my
shows have been most a robot and big
brother now those are both over I think
I'm gonna watch me leave back for the
next gentleman watch I just watch the
movies Offit's
which is awesome really good it's an
independent film by first-time writer
director and it's about this girl I like
her she's like young and she wants to
join the dance team and it's like all
this stuff it's really great I really
liked it a lot
I watch it on Amazon
worth the rent Andrew Garfield
spider-man Tobey Maguire swear I'm only
seeing the Tobey Maguire spy I like the
Miles Morales away no one needs and I
think they should have made and I don't
know why they do that that press
conference turned into a bloodbath you
tell me come on keep it down I don't
know why they didn't think Miles Morales
the new spider-man watch house of cards
I'm not I love Kevin Spacey that kind of
overwrought I kind of like it's got to
have some like things reason why I like
this robot is it very unsettling in
which gives me a lot of anxiety and it's
very there's enough going on to keep me
interested
musics amazing acting's amazing Rami
Malik's and Greta Bowles
MS bells a genius house of cards I mean
features amazing obviously the world in
which it operates just political stuff
doesn't investigation I'm not into it
I know Beth loves West Wing West Wing
was inspiring a lot of ways and I'm not
sure how sakura-con Valley is amazing
trains will hang in the background yeah
Bruce why such an echo and then
obviously I'm talking very loud like hey
there's nothing really just robots not
on Netflix it's on USA so it's good for
an 82 I think John's the entire campaign
I think it's not an Amazon yeah back
Hill cannot get away with this
the girl from mr. robot yes Portia
Doubleday was on me just like ie on our
show last week you feel like Perot who
makes me laugh glad you made it
Ashley if games done yes we will be
watching the debates tonight we have to
we're in is that Selina Kyle it is
Selina Kyle you didn't tell me you were
bringing a friend to dinner this is
Selena there's no one to root for in
house of cards so it's hard for me to
get any - that's exactly right
I completely agree should nonsense I
think we've met think we I gave you that
black high everyone knows who Bruce
Wayne is surly duck our members I
recommend the book group comedy drama
from about 10 years ago in Scotland all
right fair enough
archers amazing don't worry I'm not
gonna fall oh sorry
Selina's big jack white to the
Shakespeare Jackson not my lose the
election I guess I can Sheldon Cooper
let's just go right in what happened to
your isolator uh okay Sheldon Cooper or
Howard Wolowitz I don't know what you're
referring to people okay
I like Cooper from interstellar I'm I
get obsessed with watching scenes free
movies and I'll watch like parts of
movies like hundreds of times you walk
home and right now I am called to a car
I'm obsessed with a couple scenes from
interstellar especially the water planet
were kohalon oh and the docking scene
I've watched no joke probably 30 times
in the last week I hope no it's amazing
Nolan he's incredible and he just
finished shooting dunk her stage next to
us I saw Harry Styles walking around in
a world war one outfit yeah
Harry sauce comes out of the bathroom he
goes like this his hair was perfect and
then he hugged some production his
sister or something and then they went
and there was a bunch of I didn't see
Tom Hardy unfortunately who's like my
favorite but somebody said they saw
Nolan in a wetsuit walking because they
open this big water tank
how were they shot because it's the same
stage that where they shot perfect and
also they also shot the elevator
scene in Inception and that cave was in
there too yeah anything enormous or
whatever and no one likes to use that
stage and so outsider oh it's so funny
to like I was going to get coffee for
like a week I would see like all these
guys in World War 1 outfits just sitting
outside and was like lifeboats and stuff
around is very cool I did say Harry
Styles Toria
I can't wait me like pearl it is hard
for me to play and read comments but I
think I'm doing an okay job b-plus
sheshank Saxon I haven't seen Big Bang I
don't watch a lot of TV
unfortunately nice to meet the real you
the real me is Batman dude this means
the alter-ego it's the same thing as
super that's whether yeah you know I'm
saying Superman's the real guy Clark
Kent's the big black hole thing was
mind-blowing interstellar yo yo make it
so that's true with you it was and
actually Kip Thorne who's an amazing
physicist they he they said gargantuan
the black hole in interstellar is
actually the most realistic imagined
visualization of a black hole ever put
on film because of the equations that we
use they made a new program to simulate
a black hole so it's actually unlike the
gravity lensing you know like gravity
lensing is where there's something
that's like a black hole there's a lot
of gravity around it it's kind of like
around the edge lighting things so the
gravity lensing was like correct same
thing with the wormhole in interstellar
like the gravity lensing was supposed to
be like corrective that which is
fascinating
that's how by the way they they see
things a lot of times far away they'll
use gravity lensing to look behind
things or whatever 30 surviving people
another one being robbed who hired you
to break into the mayor's offices my
clients prefer to remain confidential
what am I going as for Halloween no no
we're gonna be in New York for Halloween
so yes I'm not sure our first shows
be going as a lady work good night yeah
I'll be going ahead be going as a super
tired person working for Conan docking
seen Deena get your mind out of the
gutter it's awesome though and also I
love the robots cars in case an
interstellar fin - so oh I intend to
just give me back the drive I'll be I
used to walk interstellar tapping a
black hole equation binary in the second
ever rich watch bit of a stretch surly
duck I agree with you
however like interstellar is not perfect
but there are some really great scenes
also when you watching the messages but
you know you got it
you gotta uh you're just you have to
give it up for Nolan like he's one of
the only people doing these epic movies
yeah he's doing think I need uses
practical effects a lot of times like
Mike on the truck flipping over in the
Dark Knight war by the way and her
stellar in the tesseract that was all
what he was practical they painted all
these lines in the wall it wasn't CG it
was he was hanging in a real room which
is really cool Titan motion can you tell
me how you ended up with Conan's show
story in a nutshell I was an intern
luckily somebody left actually I worked
my way up to whatever I'm Marsha was
what's that Tony Scott Ridley Scott
really Scott was the Martian some pieces
the Martian is fine I'd love to book was
amazing
anywhere's you're kind of really coming
for his next book no animus prime no no
he's never been on Kona I would love it
if he came out I've seen him walking
around a lot like it's just cool cuz
yeah that's what yeah that's a should be
Daenerys for Halloween maybe I won't be
Dino's
don't screw it up
it's late add no I'm not flexing but
thank you very nice to you same
Andrew sellers beautiful inner moments I
wanted to cry I agree Elbert I'm at the
warehouse
no sign of Catwoman's contact it's quiet
inter so there's gonna be a classic a
future Paul Bell I I think that Nolan I
think that and for most creative
endeavors I think if you put in a lot of
work and you do things that are
practical in terms of the effects I
think they will let the movies will last
a long time when you get into CG and
that stuff that's one of the reasons I
think my Star Wars has been so enduring
in terms of the effects because they
used models and it makes sense you know
it's like and then the new ones that not
the new new one with the old one old new
ones
this wasn't a lot of CG and people kind
of just hate that it just looks like a
video game in a bad way how many
favorite Batman villains skull of K I
like strategy games like paradox titles
yes well I'm gonna fun
I mean like a mind game yeah I don't
know that's tough we're some were some
other guys you got me Killer Croc you
got
realizing it's a volatile chemical
potential psychoactive know we're
talking scarecrow bean was great in the
comics like although you know nothing
left to bury a narc he was good I don't
know see now this is what I'm talking
about
I love it
well done telltale all that what
superpower what I wanted to did so we've
been the force ah I would say don't
think chemicals themselves wouldn't what
I want
SuperSpeed going please or you know what
what about the ability to stop time that
would be great that might better be
lonely
isn't life lonely but you know you would
need SuperSpeed if you could stop maybe
sometime I'll just go that's broken to
City Hall Zazu that's a great villain
although just like whatever just a brain
I think I would not want to read minds
definitely not yeah I don't know what I
would want the ability to turn to mist I
mean ever like flight would be funny yes
it's pretty public the thing is like
let's be us if you had a superpower
silly no one else in the history if the
world's ever happened you were going to
get captured and dissected that's gonna
happen and so you got it it's got to be
something I think that would be you hat
you can keep under wraps
you know like wouldn't be obvious flight
would be obvious
I mean like immortality would be
interesting but then obviously very sad
also
it was a great Borgess story I've called
the immortal fantastic highly
recommendable by the way how do you like
the stream we're playing video games and
talking about point of jorge gorgeous so
good but you guys should read Borges
it's great your morals is awesome it's
about a guy who theorizes that there's a
river in which if you drink out of
you'll become immortal and then he finds
it and then it's what happens after that
it's really interesting
candor ster fragment let's link it up to
the scorched remains to the thing right
I read by nature I make it orcas VR I'm
interested oh wait you're Johnson this
Kona noise little puppet dances in black
ops 3
no I haven't heard about that what is
that I know it's in like an NF some NFL
break these links oh yeah no Call of
Duty cuz he Andy do you think ya
canisters were stood here
Phoenix powers so teleport was he good
you know what I think would be I think I
think it would be great to have
I mean look man like whatever Silver
Surfer have you go out into space look
around would be cool the force closed
how about the ability to give other
people superpowers be interesting the
Agamemnon yeah what if you I did watch
Chronicle that's great shade next yeah
but what if you teleport into into
something and then you kill yourself
that's bad
so who was here when uh maybe
immortality like the ability to net
never be killed or hurt would be
interesting also it would also be very
sad but because your superpowers Lisa
wings my super virus is eating only
health exam myself the drone
yes Michaels we you're right I counted
and IDO to halo by the way that was kind
of an f-type thing because they were in
halo and then we did halo for clueless
gamer and I had to find them in the game
which was super stressful I have like a
day to do it two days to do it
and so it's like there were actually
like real stakes to me dying so I was
like I need to get there and they're
like in this second to last legs
yeah it was like a week it's like right
before you go in and fight the last
battle in the Halo game it was like
they're just hanging out in this hangar
he was like super stressful
sky like a GP rock good to see you
what's a fencer a fencer is someone who
you give them stolen goods and they will
sell it for you they're a middleman we
got a burnt cop a killed cop a clawed
cop what's going on here and we're
telling to be awful what would you do an
earth no longer exists you float around
in space man you'd have billions of
years to figure that out we have
billions of years to build spaceship to
this man's power would be cool but
parfum is power I'd be boring if you can
make people do whatever you want what's
the point
oh this is gonna be gross Wow Wow
really I love this how do I know the
bullet this is like dead this is like
the beginning of Deadwood since your son
is Indira hail NH thanks for joining us
first Rizzoli are you guys hi dr.
Manhattan would be great
you know what rain network that may be
dr. Manhattan would be awesome cuz
you're not immortal you are immortal but
you're like a being of energy yeah and
yeah I see dr. Manhattan powers would be
awesome just that scene in Watchmen and
the comic books maybe it's uh it's in
the movie to where he's just in Vietnam
he's just so you're saying like
basically the powers of the Beyonder
which I'm fine with
cuz I don't remember Adam West doing any
of this all right let's make some links
here let's make some legs ripped up face
no you're right sup everyone hates you
got lifted you added me on snapchat I
sure will
add us on snapchat at us a team coke on
snapchat no more yeah if you guys
followed us we were in Berlin there was
something real for me wait so unscored
area and palettes I think right now I'm
scorched area and yes it's got no
I'm scorched area and we loved it was
great thank you I wish where did this
look the pieces barehanded oh oh yeah
scarecrow man it's the scarecrows poison
the place to be - this is not recorded
but we are recording it this is live but
then you can watch it later if you want
I don't know that we're gonna get this
before times over a necessary bullet is
probably should be linked it with this
dude's gun or something right
like these guys shot these guys and
these guys shot these guys
need to talk about iPhone are you
talking about hello jungle Jemaine you
can see no proof proof I think we got to
go we got to go guys we got a show to do
today
please watch our show we got patton
oswalt tonight we got you know everybody
loves our second guest Joe Wow Joe Walsh
who his uncle was my philosophy
professor and tall Heights from Boston
are the musical guests and of course
lots of great comedy ah
the game was telltale games Batman super
fun game and definitely be playing
episode 2 at some point thank you for
joining us we'll see you right back here
next week at noon for another stream
kogas you guys
you